Okay, my friend. Who is the angel in
Isaiah 63:9 that saved them? It says the
angel of his face. What does it mean
he's the angel of his face? Do I have to
even break the Hebrew for you?
No. Okay, what does it mean?
>> Saved
Well, the angel of his face is
essentially the angel sent by God. Well,
what does it mean of his face?
What do you mean of his face?
>> Because that's what the text says. The
angel of his face saved them. Isaiah
63:9.
Well, that means it translates to here.
You know, I mean I guess you can If you
look at the, you know, the English
which, you know, translates his presence
necessarily.
>> Okay, even his presence. What does it
mean that the angel of his presence? My
friend, face, presence, when you talk
about his face, you talk about his
presence. The point is what does it mean
that the angel is the angel of his
presence?
Well, the angel Well, I'll tell you
what. So, the angel
would necessarily be sent in God, you
know, essentially necessarily sent in
God's presence. And what we mean by this
essentially, it's a, you know, it's it's
you know, it's a form of competition
where
Hold on. My screen My screen keeps
turning black.
>> what? You just You're going to refute
yourself, right? I just want you to be
careful what you say cuz you're going to
refute yourself. You know that, right?
Necessarily, the angel would be sent as,
you know, it basically be sent out,
right? Of God's Well, the super natural
Remember, an angel can be super natural
used to be super natural in the actual
>> presence, you're saying? Out of his
presence. Okay, no. You know why that's
not the meaning? You just read in Exodus
33:14, it says, "My presence will go
before you." Who's the presence that
went before them?
You just read in Exodus 33:14.
30 So, you said Exodus 33:14?
>> Okay, follow with me. Let's connect the
dots cuz I don't think you believe your
>> my email it does say it does say so yes
it's a vio email uh uh you know, Eli
you know, as a the honey see right Luke
Okay, let's try this again.
>> Okay, I know that. Just please your
book.
Uh brother Newmatic, since you don't
believe your Bible contradicts, it says,
"My presence will go before you. My
presence will go is going with you. So,
who is the presence if not the angel?
Because in Exodus 33, in that very same
chapter and verse two, he mentions the
angel going before them.
Well, I don't necessarily believe that I
mean that's not what I believe, so I
however,
from what you from what we can read here
that you know my presence going before
you once again can be a metaphor. So,
this is you know understood in Targum
Onkelos, you know I will no longer send
an angel my my you know I myself will
go. And that's not a metaphor by the
way. Your calling the Targum show that
God himself is showing up. How's that a
metaphor?
Well, necessarily essentially you know
punai, right? It still is a metaphor and
I'll explain why. Punai necessarily can
mean you know God's you know God's watch
you know God's protection of Yakov you
know among other people etc. And we
understand this is such because the fact
that you know not necessarily we don't
see
you know him going with you know this
person you know going right? You mean
you mean you mean God not going? You
sure he's not going? He's in the cloud
and they said they saw the God.
>> we don't necessarily see a spirit you
know right next to him right? This
essentially it is you know God's you
know protection and over him.
>> I'm confused I know. Uh when it says my
angel go ahead of you, we're not
necessarily seeing a spirit next to him?
How clear could it be it's an angel?
>> angel does not have to be a spirit. An
angel can literally be anything outside
of
outside of you know this this natural
reality that we as human beings are
bound to something
so it doesn't necessarily too fast.
Whatever you'd say outside of this
natural reality it's still an entity
that's conscious and can speak. I don't
care how you define the term. You're
playing semantics here. Whatever you
want to say about the angel, the angel's
an actually conscious sentient entity
because he speaks, can be spoken and can
be seen and even touched like you even
said Jacob wrestled with him. I don't
care how you define it. Let's stick to
the text.
>> a singular angel. It's a
It's understood understand as well. It
is a single angel because Isaiah 63:9
says, "The angel of his presence." It
didn't just say angels in plural, it
said angel in singular, one specific
one.
No, I'm saying there are different
angels across the entire Tanakh being
referred to as
>> forget about these other angels, my
friend Yossi? Uh you get you're tiring
me out because I know there are angels.
It's not one. Can we focus on this one
particular angel? It's not angels. I
know there are angels. In Daniel 8, you
have Gabriel, but that actually proves
my point because Gabriel doesn't talk
like this angel. And when he mentions
Michael, he doesn't mention Michael the
way this angel is referred to. So, can
we stop that there are other angels? No
one's denying it. Can we focus on this
angel?
This one angel that is the angel of his
presence, that God says, "My name is in
him." That Jacob invokes to bless his
grandchildren. That angel that tells
Jacob, "I'm the God of Bethel."
Can we stop going here and there and
there and focus, please?
Okay, so we can so we can focus on the
we can focus on let's say you know
chapter 33 in Exodus, right?
>> 33:2 and 14. Who's the presence?
According to Exodus 33:2 and verse 14.
Who's the presence?
>> The presence is referring to God. Okay,
can you read verse two for me? Exodus
33:2.
All right.
Um
And I will send an angel before you and
I will drive out the Canaanites, the
Amorites, the Hittites, and the
Perizzites, and the Hivites, and
>> what before you?
An angel. Now, read verse 14.
My My presence will go with you. This is
My presence will go with you. I'll go
with you.
>> Okay, so you're now going to convince
me. Convince me with a clear face as
you're going to answer to God in the day
of judgment. In that chapter, we're
told, "I'm sending my angel ahead of
you, and my presence will go before
you." And Isaiah 63:9 says, "This is the
angel of his presence." And I combine
all that and you still want me not to
see that the angel is his presence, not
simply sent out from his presence.
Convince me.
Well, the presence, for example, here it
says "punay" and the word is, you know,
you know, means face, literally
speaking. Oh, but in Isaiah 63:9 it
didn't mean face. You see what you're
doing again?
>> Oh, sorry. I thought you I thought you
were trying to use 33:14.
>> it works
You'll see. Take it step by step. The
same word used in Exodus 33:14 is used
in Isaiah 63:9. It's the same word.
Presence.
>> Yes, it's punay. Yes. Okay, but here
you're saying Let me repeat what you
just said. In 33:14, now you're saying
it's God's face. But in Isaiah 63:9,
when I said the angel of his face, "No,
no, no, it's not his face, it's his
presence." Why are you changing
definitions on me? Well, I'm not
changing definition.
What I If I If I did say it's not his
face, I apologize because I did not
finish. I don't mean like his literal
face, by the way, cuz I don't mean I do
not believe that God has a literal
created face. Now, the thing is
is that
in the Tanakh, right, especially, you
know, in these specific verses, an
angel, like I said, is not always, you
know, a physical thing or a, you know,
sort of, you know, like like Gabriel.
It's not like going to be like Gabriel.
It's not going to be like Michael. Not
Not necessarily. Angels in general are
always used as, essentially, you know, a
medium for God, you know, as he always
does things with the shaliach, with the
messenger. We're back to the same point.
I mean
We're back to the same point again.
The same point already you mentioned.
Yeah, but my friend can you show me an
angel besides this one where God says,
"My name is in him."
He will not forgive your sins if you
anger him. And then we see the angel
telling Joshua, "I removed your sins."
Or where the angel says, "I'm the God of
the house of God." Or the angel of his
presence. Why are you keep telling me a
medium? Gabriel is also a medium.
Michael is also a medium.
Okay, but you're Let's finish the point.
Gabriel's also a medium. Michael is also
a medium. But none of them say I'm the
God of the house of God. None of them
does God say my name is in them. None of
them say I forgive sins. He only says
this about this one angel who doesn't
tell us his name is Gabriel Michael, but
says that he's the God of Abraham,
Isaac, and Jacob.
Well, as I was saying
an angel does not necessarily have to be
a you know something which is closed
essence for example. And what I mean by
this is that it is essentially it can
literally just be describing an action
that God does on earth. Simple. Not him
manifesting on earth, right? That's what
I mean. What I mean is it is him, you
know, essentially, you know, doing an
action on earth, sending something. So
let's let's let's go with what you're
saying. Wait, hold on. Hold on.
We can see you know we can see here as
well it says you know he you know his
presence saved them with his love and
with his pity. Right? And he redeemed
them etc. We understand this. Now the
thing is is that God's presence as well,
or just translate you know which is a
literal term here is his face.
The thing is is that it once again it's
not necessarily his presence on earth or
an angel being, you know,
an angel being, you know, like three in
one, you know, with his presence with
the Holy Spirit.
The thing is
is that essentially his presence can
simply refer to and is refers to here as
well God's action on earth. Why does an
angel come out of his presence? Well,
the thing is is that this essentially is
also sending another intermediary out of
his, you know, out of his presence.
>> Okay, let's let's go with what you just
said because the person basically kept
telling me what you think the text
means. So when he says
>> Well, it's not necessarily What What he
says when I I'm going to send an angel
ahead of you, you just said necessarily
that's not necessarily uh someone like
Gabriel, but it may be God's action. So
let's define it by what the way you're
saying it. I'm going to send my action
ahead of you. Be careful to hear and
obey my action because my action won't
forgive you because my name is in my
action. You're serious?
No, no, no. I You're misunderstanding
what I'm saying.
>> No, I understood perfectly. I'm trying
to show the absurdity of your argument
cuz you have no objection. That's what
I'm trying to show. I understood you
perfectly. So, let's take it as an
intermediate.
>> I say? Yeah, you just said that an angel
can be an intermediate that God sends
from his presence. I heard you
perfectly. So, let's go with that
definition. Let's go with that
definition. Okay. This angel is an
intermediate sent by God. Okay. But,
this intermediate God says of him, "My
name is in him. He won't forgive you."
How many intermediate
beings do you have that God says this
about? Does he say this about Gabriel
and Michael?
No. Okay. So, what makes this angel so
special that God says, "My name is in
him. He won't forgive you." Meaning has
the power to forgive. And what makes
this angel so special that when Abraham
of Jacob prays, he invokes the angel to
bless his grandchildren. What makes this
angel so special that he says, "I am the
God of the house of God." Why is this
angel so special that he talks as if
he's God? God speaks of him as if he's
God. And he does things that only God
can do. But, this is not said of any
other angel, any other intermediate
being.
Well, it does Like I said,
when you you I the concept of angels in
the Tanakh, okay,
is not is not always going to be a
physical being, right? Like like a like
let's say like a light, like a ball of
light in the garden of Eden. Well, not
always. So, what did we have Jacob
wrestling with?
>> Hold on, wait. I do want to finish my
point. I want to finish my point.
>> ahead. The thing is, right? Is that when
you say,
okay, well, why is he saying that he is
God? Why is he speaking in the first
person? The reason why is cuz this is
the medium that God speaks through,
okay? So, the angel as well in many
cases, so for example, when he when he
is speaking to you know, Joshua and
Joshua is seeking redemption from him,
right? This is simply the way that God
is interacting with his creation. Now,
does this mean that God is coeternal or
one with the angel or the angels in the
sense of the time God had with him?
>> Yes. The reason why
is
the reason why is primarily because, as
I described, it is an intermediary, not
just an actual It means any sort of
supernatural
>> You know, you know, you know, you know,
we're we're we're going in circles,
right? This is why I tried to stop you
because you think you're making a point,
but I've refuted you over and over
again. I'm going to try it a third time.
We're going to move to something else
because you're spinning wheels is an
intermediate of God.
Michael is an intermediate of God. None
of them say, "I am the God of X, Y, and
Z." None of them say that I forgive your
sins and I remove you of your sins. So,
your concept of agency, intermediary
does not work. I thought I was clear the
first 50,000 times when I addressed your
point. That's why I stopped you.
Because if it's common, well, let me
explain. If it was common for
intermediate
beings to speak this way, then why
doesn't Gabriel speak this way? Why
doesn't Michael speak this way? In fact,
why doesn't Joshua speak this way?
Because he is God's agent, intermediate,
standing between God and Israel.
Intermediate beings do not speak this
way.
Was Moses not called God? Okay, to
Pharaoh, right? In position.
Okay. Who's talking about being called
God to Pharaoh? I'll make you God to
Pharaoh cuz he stands in the place of
God. I want to know where where God
says, "My name is in Moses. Moses won't
forgive you." And then Moses comes
around and says, "Hey, I'm the God of
the house of God and I remove your sins
and I clothe you with righteousness."
Can you show me where Moses speaks like
that?
I do not have an example for you.
However, You don't have it cuz it
doesn't exist.
Is it prophets? Are as well intermediary
intermediary? Yes.
However, Thank you.
I mean I am once again, what I am saying
is as well. So, for example, Moses split
the, you know, So, split the sea. When
he split the sea, you know, you know, do
it You sure he split the sea? You
positive? You positive he split the sea?
Do I have to correct your misreading of
your own Tanakh?
Well, I'm saying God split the sea, you
know, he put his staff in the sea. He
didn't split anything. God commanded an
east wind. God split the sea by bringing
in that east wind when Moses lifted up
his rod. It had nothing to do with
Moses. That was my point. That was my
point. That's what I was saying. That's
a terrible point. Can I tell you why
it's a terrible point? Because the same
God that's called the wind, the east
wind to split the sea, was there in a
cloud and the angel was there with him.
Was Moses in the cloud riding the cloud?
No. Was the angel in the cloud directing
the cloud?
>> No. Go to Exodus 14:19 and 20. Yes. Yes.
So, you say God was in the cloud. Yes,
it says so. Okay, no. Was the angel
controlling the cloud so that he was in
the cloud?
No. I I I
>> Exodus 14:19 and 20.
Exodus 14:19 and 20.
Read that for me.
And the angel of God who had been going
in front of the Israelite camp moved and
went behind them, and the pillar of the
cloud moved away from them
moved away and in front of them and
stood behind them. Read 14:19 and 20
slowly again. Who's directing the cloud?
When he moves, the cloud moves. So, read
it again.
>> The angel. The angel. Okay, wait, wait.
So, I want everyone to hear it. So, you
see in your text the angel guides the
cloud. When he moves, it moves. So, if
he goes behind, the cloud is behind. If
he goes in front, the cloud is in front,
right?
Mhm. And so, why did you just tell me
the angel's not in the cloud?
I I I said that by mistake.
>> Okay, that's fine. So, now let's we got
a couple more references. We're going to
wrap it up. Hopefully, I'll talk to you
more because if you're honest to God,
you're going to give up on your Judaism
and stop joining Muslims bashing
Christians lest we bash you in return.